¿Sabían que el año pasado,
durante 299 días,
no usamos ningún combustible fósil
para generar electricidad?
Es un logro fantástico
y, sin embargo, esconde una paradoja,
y es que casi el 70 %
de todo nuestro consumo de energía es petróleo.
¿Por qué?
Debido a nuestro sistema de transporte,
que es totalmente dependiente de los combustibles fósiles,
como lo es en la mayoría de los países.
Si pensamos en la transición energética como una maratón,
la pregunta es, ¿cómo podemos llegar a la meta?
¿cómo podemos "descarbonizar" el resto de la economía?
Y podemos decir que si no tenemos éxito,
es difícil ver quién lo hará.
Por eso es que quiero hablarles de Costa Rica,
porque creo que somos un gran candidato
pionero sobre una visión de desarrollo sin combustibles fósiles.
Si deben saber algo sobre nuestro país,
es que no tenemos ejército.
Así que vayamos a 1948.
Ese año, el país estaba saliendo de una guerra civil.
Miles de costarricenses habían muerto,
y las familias se dividieron amargamente.
Y sin embargo, una idea sorprendente se ganó los corazones y las mentes:
reiniciaríamos el país,
y la Segunda República no tendría ejército.
Así que se abolió.
Y el presidente en ese momento,
José Figueres,
encontró una manera potente de romper las paredes de la base militar.
Al año siguiente, 1949,
fijamos esa decisión de forma permanente en la nueva constitución,
y por eso puedo contar esta historia casi 70 años después.
Estoy muy agradecida.
Estoy agradecida de que hayan tomado esa decisión antes de haber nacido,
porque me permitió a mí y a millones de personas
vivir en un país muy estable.
Podrían pensar que fue buena suerte,
pero no lo fue.
Hubo un patrón de acciones deliberadas.
En los años 40, los costarricenses tenían educación y atención médica gratuita.
Lo llamamos garantías sociales.
Al abolir el ejército,
pudimos convertir el gasto militar en gasto social,
y eso supuso un impulso a la estabilidad.
En los años 50...
(Aplausos)
En los años 50, comenzamos a invertir en energía hidroeléctrica,
y eso nos mantuvo lejos de la trampa
de usar combustibles fósiles para generar electricidad,
que es con lo que el mundo está luchando hoy día.
En los años 70 se invirtió en los parques nacionales,
eso nos mantuvo alejados
de la lógica profundamente defectuosa del crecimiento a cualquier precio
al que se aferran, especialmente en el mundo en desarrollo.
En los años 90 fuimos pioneros en pagos por servicios ambientales,
y eso nos ayudó a revertir la deforestación
y aumentó el ecoturismo, que hoy es un motor clave del crecimiento.
Por lo tanto, invertir en protección ambiental
no perjudica nuestra economía.
Todo lo contrario.
Y eso no quiere decir que seamos perfectos
y que no tengamos contradicciones.
Esa no es la idea.
La idea es que, al tomar nuestras propias decisiones,
pudimos desarrollar resiliencia frente a los problemas de desarrollo.
Además, si toman un país como el nuestro,
el PIB per cápita es de unos USD 11 000,
dependiendo de cómo se mida.
Pero de acuerdo con el Índice de Progreso Social,
somos una excepción
cuando se trata de convertir el PIB en progreso social.
La abolición del ejército,
la inversión en la naturaleza y la gente,
produjo algo muy potente también.
Dio forma a la narrativa,
la narrativa de un pequeño país con grandes ideas,
y fue muy enriquecedor crecer con esa narrativa.
Entonces la pregunta es:
¿cuál es la próxima gran idea para esta generación?
Y creo que lo que viene a continuación
para esta generación es abandonar los combustibles fósiles,
tal como lo hicimos con el ejército.
Los combustibles fósiles propician el cambio climático.
Lo sabemos,
y sabemos lo vulnerables que somos a los impactos del cambio climático.
Como país en desarrollo, es en nuestro mejor interés
construir el desarrollo sin combustibles fósiles
que puedan dañar a las personas en primer lugar.
Porque,
¿por qué seguimos importando petróleo
para transporte
si podemos usar electricidad?
Recuerden,
este es el país
donde la electricidad proviene del agua de nuestros ríos,
del calor de los volcanes,
de turbinas eólicas, paneles solares,
residuos biológicos.
Abolir los combustibles fósiles es abolir nuestro sistema de transporte
para alimentar nuestros automóviles, autobuses y trenes con electricidad
en lugar de energía sucia.
Y el transporte, han de saber,
es una cuestión existencial para nosotros los costarricenses,
porque el modelo que tenemos no nos está funcionando.
Hace daño a la gente,
perjudica a las empresas,
y daña nuestra salud.
Porque cuando fallan las políticas y la infraestructura,
eso es lo que sucede a diario.
Dos horas por la mañana,
dos horas por la tarde.
No entiendo por qué tenemos que aceptar esto como normal.
Es ofensivo
tener que perder el tiempo así todos los días.
Y esta carretera es bastante buena
en comparación con lo que se ve en otros países
donde el tránsito explota.
Los costarricenses lo llamamos "presa".
Presa significa "encarcelado".
Y las personas están recurriendo a la violencia
en un país que, por otro lado, es feliz y "pura vida".
Está sucediendo.
Así que hay mucho en juego.
Las buenas noticias
es que cuando hablamos de transporte limpio
y de movilidad diferente,
no estamos hablando de una utopía lejana.
Estamos hablando de la movilidad eléctrica que sucede hoy en día.
Para el año 2022, los autos eléctricos y convencionales
se espera que tengan el mismo costo,
y las ciudades ya están usando autobuses eléctricos.
Y estas criaturas tan "cool"
ahorran dinero,
y reducen la contaminación.
Así que si queremos deshacernos del transporte a base de petróleo, podemos,
porque ahora tenemos opciones que no teníamos antes.
Eso es muy emocionante.
Pero por supuesto,
a algunos incomoda esta idea,
y vendrán y dirán
que el mundo depende del petróleo y también Costa Rica, sean realistas.
Eso es lo que dicen.
¿Saben cuál es la respuesta a ese argumento?
Que en 1948 no dijimos que dado que el mundo dependía de los ejércitos,
por eso íbamos a mantener nuestro ejército, también.
No, tomamos una decisión muy valiente,
y esa decisión marcó la diferencia.
Es hora de que esta generación sea valiente de nuevo
para abolir los combustibles fósiles.
Voy a dar tres razones por las que tenemos que hacer esto.
Primero,
nuestro modelo de transporte y urbanización no funciona;
hoy es el mejor momento para redefinir el futuro urbano y la movilidad.
No queremos que las ciudades se construyan para los autos.
Queremos ciudades para las personas
donde podamos caminar y usar las bicicletas.
Y queremos que haya mucho
transporte público,
transporte público limpio y digno.
Porque si seguimos añadiendo flotas de autos convencionales,
nuestras ciudades serán inhabitables.
En segundo lugar, tenemos que cambiar,
pero con un cambio incremental no va a ser suficiente.
Necesitamos un cambio que transforme.
Y hay algunos proyectos incrementales en mi país,
y yo soy la primera en celebrarlos.
Pero vamos, no nos engañemos.
No estamos hablando de tener autos eléctricos bonitos aquí
y algunos autobuses eléctricos allá
mientras sigamos invirtiendo en el mismo tipo de infraestructuras,
más autos, más carreteras, más petróleo.
Estamos hablando de liberarnos del petróleo
y no se puede lograr eso de manera incremental.
En tercer lugar, y ya saben esto,
el mundo está ávido de inspiración.
Anhela historias de éxito
para hacer frente a cuestiones complejas,
especialmente en los países en desarrollo.
Creo que Costa Rica puede ser una inspiración para los demás,
como hicimos el año pasado, cuando divulgamos
los días que tenemos sin usar ningún combustible fósil
para generar toda la electricidad.
La noticia se difundió en todo el mundo.
También, y esto me hace sentir muy orgullosa,
una mujer de Costa Rica, Christiana Figueres, desempeñó un papel decisivo
en las negociaciones del acuerdo sobre el clima de París.
Así que tenemos que proteger ese legado y ser un ejemplo.
Entonces, ¿qué viene después?
La gente.
¿Cómo hacer que la gente se apropie de esto?
¿Cómo hacer que la gente
crea que es posible
construir una sociedad sin combustibles fósiles?
Se necesita mucho trabajo desde cero.
Por eso, en 2014, creamos Costa Rica Limpia.
Y decimos "Limpia"
porque queremos potenciar e inspirar a los ciudadanos.
Si los ciudadanos no se comprometen,
las decisiones de transporte limpio no progresarán
y me refiero a las discusiones técnicas interminables,
y a las avalanchas de cabildeo por diversos intereses establecidos.
Querer ser un país verde alimentado por energías renovables
ya es parte de nuestra historia.
No debemos dejar que nadie nos quite eso.
El año pasado, trajimos gente de nuestros siete cantones
para hablar del cambio climático en términos importantes para ellos,
y también trajimos este año
otro grupo de costarricenses
para hablar de las energías renovables.
¿Y saben qué?
Estas personas discrepan en casi todo
salvo en energías renovables
y en transporte y aire limpio.
Eso une a las personas.
Y la clave para una participación real
es ayudar a la gente a no sentirse pequeña.
Las personas se sienten impotentes,